I was doomed from the start. Why does one run towards ruin? Why does it hold such a fascination?
Your appreciation has been most intelligent
i congratulate you on the success of your performance
What I'm saying is that I have lived in the grip of vice and pleasure.
Oscar Wilde
The sentence of the court is that you'll be imprisoned and kept to hard labor for two years
It was wrong and I have paid.
It will make a Catholic of you yet.
Only unlike dear Jesus you have luggage
I fully intend to effect a reconciliation with my wife
I feel sure that if I was to see him once I would forgive him everything
Rest assured, I shall never see Lord Alfred Douglas again.
I forbid him to live with that infernal man
Oscar, let's run away. Somewhere no one could find us.
You don't know what you're saying
Then you will never see Constance again
Not wearing your silk stockings today, Oscar?
You go too far, sir
No,  you go too far
You've taken everything: my family, my work, my freedom! Everything!  There's nothing left to take!
Suffering is nothing when there is love.
Love is everything
I must love and be loved, but the price I pay for it
Mr. Wilde?  How kind of you to speak to me.  You couldn't lend me five pounds, could you?
I'm in mortal combat with this wallpaper, Robbie, and one of us has to go
You